on the faraway island of Salamis and
yertle the turtle was king of the pond a
nice little pond it was clean it was
neat the water was warm there was plenty
to eat the turtles had everything
Turtles might need and they were all
happy quite happy indeed they were until
you're at all the king of them all the
side of the kingdom he ruled was too
small I'm ruler said Yertle of all that
I see but I don't see enough that's the
trouble with me with a stone for a
throne I look down on my pond but I
cannot look down on the places beyond
this throne that I sit on is too too low
down it ought to be higher he said with
a frown if I could sit high how much
greater I'd be what a king I'd be ruler
of all I could see so Yertle the Turtle
lifted his hand and urinal the turtle
king gave a command
he ordered nine turtles to swim to a
stone and using those Turtles he built a
new throne he made each turtle stand on
another one's back and he piled them all
up in a nine total stack and then Yertle
climbed up he sat down on the pile what
a wonderful view he could see almost a
mile oh line yordle cried of the fed all
the things that I now rule I'm king of a
cow and I'm king of a mule and I'm king
of a house and what's more beyond that
I'm king of a blueberry bush and a cat
I'm yodel the turtle Oh marvelous me for
I'm the turtle the ruler of all that I
see and all through that morning he sat
up there high saying over and over a
great king am I too long about noon then
he heard a faint sigh what's that
snap the turtle and he looked down the
stack and he saw at the bottom a turtle
named Mac just a part of his throne and
this plain little turtle looked up and
he said beg your pardon
King Yertle
our pains in my back and my shoulders
and knees how long must we stand here
Your Majesty please silence the king of
the turtle barked back I'm King and
you're only a turtle named Mac you stay
in your place while I sit here and rule
I'm king of a cow and I'm king of a mule
I'm king of a house and a bush and a cat
and that isn't all I'll do better than
that my throne should be higher he's his
royal voice thundered so pilot turtles
I want bail two hundred Turtles more
Turtles he bellowed and braids and the
turtles way down the pond were afraid
they trembled they shook but they came
they obeyed from all over the pond
they came swimming by dozens whole
families of turtles with uncles and
cousins and all of them stepped on the
head of poor Mac one after another they
climbed up the stack then urinal the
turtle was pushed up so high he could
see 40 miles from his throne in the sky
hooray he said Yertle I'm king of the
trees I'm king of the birds and I'm king
of the bees I'm king of the butterflies
king of the air and me what a throne
what a wonderful chair I'm your little
the turtle Oh marvelous me for I am the
ruler of all that I see then again from
below and the great heavy stack came a
moan from that plain little turtle named
Mac your majesty please I don't like to
complain but down here below we're
feeling great pain I know up on top
you're seeing great sights but down to
the bottom we too should have rights we
turtles can't stand it our shells will
all crack besides we need food we're
starving growing back you hush up your
mouth pal that mighty your King Yertle
you've no right to talk of the world to
the world's highest turtle I rule from
the clouds over land over seeing there's
nothing no nothing that's higher than me
but while he was shouting a saw was
surprised that the moon of the evening
was starting to rise up over
his head and the darkening skies what's
that
snorted Yertle say what is that thing
that dares to be higher than your Erdal
the King I shall not allow it I'll go
higher still I'll build my throne higher
I can and I will
I'll call some more turtles I'll stock
him to heaven I need about five thousand
six hundred and seven I'm gonna hurdle
the turtle lifted his hand and started
to order and give the command that plain
little turtle down below and the stack
that plain little turtle whose name was
just Mac decided he'd taken enough and
he had and that plain little lad got a
little bit mad and that plain little Mac
did a plain little thing he burped and
his burp shook the throne of the king
and your and all the turtle the king of
the trees the king of the air and the
birds and the bees the king of a house
on a cow and a mule well that was the
end of the turtle King's rule for Yertle
the king of all Salomon Saund
fell off his high throne and fell plunk
in the pond and today the great Ural
that marvelous he is king of the mud
that is all he can see and the turtles
of course all the turtles are free as
Turtles and maybe all creatures should
be
so that of course was dr. Seuss's yertle
the turtle it's one of the stories that
soos wrote in the immediate aftermath of
World War two and I think it's
significant we read it in relation to
the story of Hitler Mussolini the other
dictators that soos had been very
involved in struggling against guy
theater Geisel who was dr. Seuss had
served in the American military during
World War two he'd been part of a
propaganda unit created by Frank Capra
the filmmaker to tell America why or in
war what what the meaning of this
conflict was all about the interesting
thing is when when Capra formed the unit
he brought together a number of
children's book lot writers both
American and British to work with him in
crafting the propaganda messages of
World War two among them were Eric
Knight who wrote lassie come home
Munro who wrote Ferdinand the bull the
burn Sam Bernstein who would write the
Bernstein Bear books several others who
became associated with that unit all had
formed their relationship during and
they were working with animators like
Chuck Jones who would later animate the
Seuss cartoon specials that many of us
grew up watching on Tom television so
there was a kind of collective effort
there that shaped in a profound way the
way soos understood the world and so as
I talk to you tonight about dr. Seuss
we're gonna talk a little bit about
pre-war and post-war Seuss because
that's really in many ways the defining
moment in dr. Seuss's career but the
interesting thing is to think about the
American Christmas as it comes to us
today
defined by really two classic texts How
the Grinch Cersei saved the Grinch saved
Christmas stole Christmas I'm sorry
matter of perspective makalah Grinch
Stole Christmas and it's a wonderful
life so the two members of that unit
probably shaped more of our holiday
experiences than most of us realized and
it's sort of an interesting starting
point to think about who dr. Seuss is
and the world that he created for us so
it's my plenary Jenkins the director
co-director of the comparative Media
Studies program here at MIT and it's my
solemn honor to welcome you to the 18th
annual salute to dr. Seuss I say solemn
because in all likelihood this will be
the last year that I'm presenting the
dr. Seuss salute
I started this tradition and when just
after I arrived at MIT as a young
assistant professor in the literature
department dr. Seuss had just passed
away and as I was talking to colleagues
and the faculty around the faculty area
we sort of realized that Seuss had been
a significant figure in her life and in
the lives of our students that in many
ways he was an embodiment of a
particular attitude that I think suits
MIT like a glove it's an attitude
celebrates the imagination creativity
exploration going beyond limits it's
what I think MIT at its best represents
and so we sploshed the salute the first
year we packed this room people have
been coming back ever since and various
number some years high some years now
hello but I've been at it for the full
time that I've been at MIT and
unfortunately or fortunately depending
on your perspective I announced a few
months ago then I'm leaving MIT to move
to USC I'm certainly would be delighted
if there was energy in the community at
MIT to continue this tradition but the
energy is gonna have to come from people
other than me and so I'm hoping as we
present this year that the challenge
goes out maybe someone else in the MIT
community will pick up the torch and
keep the sleuth alive but I think that
tonight is my chance to share review
some of the things I love best about
Seuss and I've chosen a bunch of
favorites of mine some of them will be
stories you know already
some of them will be stories you may not
have encountered before I always try to
mix and match some of soups
veteran-owned works and some of his
lesser-known works there was a period of
time not when we first started to salute
eighteen years ago that six of the top
ten best-selling children's books of all
time had been written by dr. Seuss
now those books have moved down the
ladder a little bit primarily as a
result of JK Rowling who stole an awful
lot of those slots at the top of a chart
but it's really an incredible
accomplishment for Seuss - a written six
of the ten best-selling books the
longside Wizard of Oz and Charlotte's
Web and a few other things that you no
doubt know the interesting thing the
Newbery Award just can't were announced
today and Neil Gaiman who did our Judah
Schwartz lecture this year won for the
graveyard book we're all very excited
for Neil the interesting thing is dr.
Seuss having written all of those
popular books never received a new
Berrie award never received a call to
Cod award never got the official
recognition of the librarians and
children's book publishers he was a
popular success but not a critical
success for most of his career prior to
the 1950s late 1950s 1960s he was not a
commercial success either and the
interesting thing is that really the
books we know from Seuss the ones that
have sold him the most were those that
were published from the late 1950s into
the early 1960s a particular period of
time and part of what I want to try to
get across he's an understanding of why
that might be why Seuss's works ii think
that i saw saw it on Mulberry Street
being one that was still beloved today
published in the late 1930s but didn't
have either critical or commercial
success until much much much later
so having started with ural I wanted to
look at another Seuss book of that
immediate post-war period this one
Horton here is the who was dedicated to
a Japanese educator and I think many
people probably don't notice the
dedications on this book but it's
dedicated to my firm for my great friend
matsuki nakamura of kyoto japan and the
dedication refers to a trip that Seuss
had taken to Japan in the immediate
aftermath
the world war 2 that America was still
occupying Japan that he having dedicated
themselves to articulating the values of
democracy during World War two at least
from an American perspective saw him
there to be an important role for
America and helping Japan move from an
imperial society to what they hoped
would be a more democratic society in
other words as a period of
nation-building that
soos found himself involved with and so
he wrote this book for the Japanese the
question is whether it is to the
Japanese or to the Americans and I think
you could argue some of both but it
tries to articulate some of the values
of citizenship in a Democratic Society I
don't think I'm stretching things that
see suits as being having to
fundamentally at this moment its career
a deeply political vision of the role of
children's literature at the University
of Utah around that period Heatley he
delivered a series of lectures about
children's literature in which he talks
about it as the biggest hope for
democracy that Seuss had come out of
World War two disillusioned by the
failures of America to embrace the
values of democracy that he thought the
war was going to be about he had been a
political radical of sorts in the
immediate pre-war period wrote for a
publication called p.m. magazine which
where he was the editorial cartoonist
and recently this book came out that dr.
Seuss goes to war which reprints his
editorial cartoons many of which are
progressive if not radical and their
politics and his vision of democracy was
he what he thought the war was about was
battling those people who would push
other people around it was very simple
democracy was about equality it was
about opportunity it was about freedom
so when we think about Yertle the Turtle
as the dictator there's no question that
his Mac the turtle whose perspective
soos embraces in that story there's no
question that the attacks assertion
right against rights against the
powerful was very close to the
democratic imagination that dr. Seuss
created and even and in many ways horton
hears the who was even more powerful
statement about citizenship and about
the value of democracy so a me with my
reading glasses on
on the 15th of May in the jungle of nool
in the heat of the day and the cool of
the pool he was splashing enjoying the
jungles Greyjoy's when Horton the
Elephant heard a small noise so Horton
stopped splashing he looked toward the
sound that's funny thought Horton
there's no one around and then he heard
it again just a very faint Yelp as if
some tiny person was calling for help
I'll help you said nor Horton but who
are you where he looked and he looked he
could not see he could see nothing there
but a small speck of dust blowing passed
through the air
I say murmured Horton I never heard tell
of a small speck of dust that was able
to yell so you know what I think why I
think there must be someone on top of
that small speck of dust some sort of a
creature a very small size too small to
be seen by an elephant's eyes some poor
little person whose shaking with fear
that he'll blow in the pool he's no way
to steer I'll just have to save him
because after all a person's a person no
matter how small so gently and using the
greatest of care the elephant's
stretched his great trunk through the
air and he lifted the dust speck and
carried it over and he placed it down
safe on a very soft clover hump pumped a
voice it was a sour kangaroo and the
young kangaroo and her pouch said humph
- why that speck is as small as the head
of a pin
a person on that why there never has
been
believe me said Horton I'll tell you
sincerely my ears are quite keen and I
heard him quite clearly I know there's a
person down there and what's more quite
likely there's two even three even four
quite likely a family fall don't we know
a family with children just starting to
grow so pleased Horton said as a favor
to me try not to disturb them just
please let them be I think you're a fool
said the sour kangaroo and the young
kangaroo and her pouch said me
- you're the biggest blame fool in the
jungle of nool and the Kangaroos plunged
and the cool of the pool what terrible
splashing the elephant frowned I can't
let my very small persons get drowned
I've got to protect them I'm bigger than
they so he plucked up the clover and
hustled away through the high jungle
treetops the news quickly spread he
talks to a dust speck he's out of his
head just look at him walk with that
speck on that flower and Horton walked
whirring almost an hour should I put the
speck down Horton thought with alarm if
I do then small persons may come to
great harm I can't put it down and I
want after all a person's a person no
matter how small then Horton stopped
walking the speck voice was talking the
voice was so faint that he could just
barely hear it speak up please said
Horton he put his ear near it my friend
came the voice you're a very fine friend
you helped all of us people on this dust
speck no end you saved all our houses
our ceilings and floors you saved all
our churches and grocery stores you mean
Horton gasp you have buildings there -
oh yes pipe the voice we most certainly
do
I know called the voice I'm too small to
be seen but I'm mayor of a town that is
friendly and clean our buildings of you
would seem terribly small but to us who
aren't big they're wonderfully tall my
town is called Whoville for I'm a who
and we whose are all thankful and
grateful to you and Horton called back
to the mayor of the town
you're safe now don't worry I won't let
you down but just as he spoke to the
mayor of the speck three big jungle
monkeys climbed up Hortons neck the
Wickersham brothers came shouting what
what the elephant's talking to who's who
are not darn any whose and they don't
have a mayor and we're gonna stop all
this nonsense so they're they snatched
portance clover they carried it off to a
block bottom the Eagle named Vlad
vladakov a mighty strong ego
a very swift ring and they said will you
kindly get rid of this thing and before
the poor elephant even could speak that
eagle flew off with the flower and his
beak all that late afternoon and far
into the night that black bottom bird
flapped his wings and fast flight while
horton chased after with groans over
stones that tattered his toenails and
battered his bones and begged please
don't harm all those little folks who
have as much right to live as us bigger
folks do but follow far beyond him
that Eagle kept flapping and over his
shoulders called back quit your yapping
I'll fly the night through I'm a bird I
don't mind it and I'll fly this tomorrow
when you'll never I'll hide this
tomorrow when you'll never find it
and at 6:56 the next morning he did it
it sure was a terrible place that he hid
it he left a little the small clover
dropped somewhere inside of a great
patch of clovers a hundred miles wide
fine that's near the beard the bird but
I think you will fail and he left with a
flip of his black bottoms tail I'll find
it said Horton I'll find you to bust I
shall find my friends on my small speck
of dust and clover by clover by clover
with care he picked up and searched them
and called are you there but clover by
clover by clover he found that the one
that he sought for was just not around
and by noon poor old Horton more dead
than alive had picked searched and piled
up nine thousand and five then on
through the afternoon hour after hour
till he found them at last on the three
millionth flower my friends cry the
elephant tell me do tell are you safe or
you sound or you hole are you well from
down on the speck came the voice of the
mayor we've really had trouble much more
than our share when that black bottom
birdie let go when we dropped we land it
so hard that our clocks have all stopped
our tea pots are broken our rocking
chairs smashed and our bicycle tires all
up when we crashed so Porton please
pleaded the voice of the mayor will you
stick by us whose while we're making
repairs of course Orton answered of
course I will stick I'll stick by you
small folks through thin and through
thick hump hump the voice for almost two
days you run wild and insisted on
chatting with persons who've never
existed such carrying ons at our
peaceable jungle we've had enough of
your bellowing bungle and I'm here to
state it's not the big Alec kangaroo
that your silly nonsensical game is all
through and the young kangaroo and her
pal said me too with the help of the
Wickersham brothers and dozens of
Wickersham uncles and Wickersham cousins
and Wickersham in-laws whose help i've
engaged you're gonna be roped and you're
gonna be caged and as for your dust back
ha that we shall boil in a hot steaming
kettle of bezel nut oil boil it gasps
horton oh that you can't do it is all
full of Persons they'll prove it to you
mr. mayor mr. mayor Horton called mr.
mayor you've got to prove now that you
really are there so call a big meeting
get everyone out make every who holler
make every who shout make every who
scream if you don't every who is going
to end up in a bezel nuts - and down on
the dust speck the scared little mayor
quick called a big meeting in Whoville
Town Square and his people cried loudly
they cried out in fear we're here we're
here we're here we're here
the elephant's smile that was clear as a
bell you can Roush surely heard that
very well
all I heard snapped the big kangaroo was
the breeze and the faint sound of the
wind through the far-distant trees I
heard no small voices and you didn't
either and the young kangaroo and the
pouch said me neither
grab him there shout and uncaged the big
dope lasso his stomach with ten miles of
rope tie the knots tight so he'll never
shake loose then dunk the dumb speck in
the Beatles up
bezel knock juice Hortons fought back
with great vigor and vim but the
Wickersham gang was too many for him
they beat him they mauled him they
started to haul him into his cage but he
managed a call to the mayor don't get up
I believe in you all a person's a person
no matter how small and you very small
persons will not have to die if you make
yourself heard so come on now and try
the mayor grabbed a TomTom he started to
smack it and all her Whoville they
hooked up a rocket they rattled ten
kettles they beat on brass pans on
garbage pail tops and on cold cranberry
cans they blew on bazookas and blasted
great toots on clarinets boom paws and
boom paws and flutes great Gustav loud
rocket rang high through the air they
rattled and shook the whole sky and the
mayor called out through the howling mad
huh Lulu hey Horton house this is their
sound coming through and Horton called
buck I can hear you just fine but the
Kangaroos ears aren't as strong quite as
mine they don't hear a thing are you
sure all your boys are doing their best
or the all making noise or are you sure
every who down in who-ville is working
quick look through your town is there
anyone shirking through the town rush
the mayor from east to the west but
everyone seemed to be doing his best
everyone seemed to be yapping ripping
everyone seemed to be beeping or dipping
but it wasn't enough all that ruckus and
war he had to find someone to help him
make more he raced through each building
he searched floor to floor and just as
he felt he was getting nowhere and
almost about to give up in despair he
suddenly burst through a door and that
mayor discovered one shirker quite
hidden away and the fairfax apartments
apartment 12
j a very small very small shirker named
Joe Joe was standing just standing and
bouncing a yo-yo then making a sound not
a Yip not a chirp and the mayor rushed
inside and he grabbed the young twerp
and he climbed through the lad up the
Eiffel
bird tower this scoid the mayor is our
town's darkest hour the time for all
who's who have blood that his Reds to
come to the aid of their country he said
we've got to make noises and great
amounts so open your mouth loud for
every voice counts when he spoke as he
climbed when they got to the top the lab
cleared his throat and he showered out
and that yup that one extra small extra
yup put it over finally at last from
that speck on that clover their voices
were heard they rang out clear and clean
and the elephant's smiled you see what I
mean they proved that you are a persons
no matter how small and their whole
world was saved by the smallest of all
how true yes how true said the big
kangaroo and from now on you know what
I'm planning to do from now on I'm going
to protect them with you in the young
kangaroo and her pouch said me to from
Sun in the summer from rain when it's
fallish I'm going to protect them no
matter how smallish Americans who didn't
contribute to the war effort people who
didn't plant Victory Gardens people who
didn't ration food who didn't save
stamps who didn't contribute twine and
wire and all of the other activities
that were set up on the homefront to
allow people to support the troops
overseas and so when Seuss refers to
Jojo as a shirker I think it has a very
specific connotation in the context of
post-world War two Society that he's
describing a time which in his life he
felt like everyone in the society had
worked toward a common interest toward
the common good and the sense of
collective action rings loudly here when
we described the mayor mobilizing all
the who's down in Whoville - out to
protect their community and against it
were posed is a pressure for conformity
a kind of name-calling a kind of
finger-pointing attitude which has taken
root in the post-war society there's a
cartoon that suits drew for Life
magazine there
the same time period and which people
people in all directions are accusing
each other of being communist so babies
are pointing that their mothers from
their crib that birds are pouring eggs
that people are pointing in all
directions and it's sort of this sense
of a society turned inward on itself
accusing itself of bad behavior refusing
the tolerate people who are different
and listen to the voices of the smallest
of the small and so when Seuss wrote the
story I think what he's speaking to is
that contrast between a citizenship that
works toward a collective action toward
pooling its efforts to the common good
and the contrast of a society turned
upon itself
accusing name-calling a series of
cultural divides and cultural warfare
that I think we recognize down to our
present day so I think the politics of
Seuss in this book is one in favor of
collective action but opposed to forced
conformity in favor of the values of
community but frightened by the power of
a mom and it's a deep debate in American
society about those two forces that I
think Seuss tried to create this book to
introduce the gun to kids and soos was
part of a whole generation of authors
who had in that post-war period were
trying at a time to trying to introduce
democracy to young people who were
promoting the United Nations for example
who were torn or worried about the war
world under the threat of atomic bombs
and said the only hope of the future was
to treat young people to embed democracy
and their pablum as Seuss put it in one
a letter that he wrote during that time
period the democracy becomes something
that people have sorbed through the
micro practices of their everyday lives
that living in home they understood
democracy because the home was being
reinvented to take away some of the
authority of adults and they embraced
the rights of young people the rights of
children that schools are being
reimagined to have more powerful student
presses and more powerful student
government's as a way of introducing
democracy into the very fabric of the
lies of this next generation and pursues
this also was a war for equality a
Wharton and i'll Seuss had felt guilty
for many of his pre-war works that have
[ __ ] as sort of stereotypical kids
which are you know yellow faced people
with
you know go to hats and chopsticks
running you know running through the
streets with pigtails you know he
represented a lot of ethnic humor and
racial humor and his pre-war work and
you don't see that in the post-war book
work and he talks about this openly in
the lectures he's giving at the
University of Utah but one of the things
that children's literature could do
would it would encourage people to
embrace diversity to embrace difference
in one way or another and I think as
soos moves in this post-war period he's
taking that ability he had from very
early in his career for the 20s for he
was creating humor for adults that were
based on exotic creatures and strange
lands and he turned it into imagining a
world of diversity creativity a world of
the imagination that oh that was
encourage people to embrace difference
to celebrate diversity and to explore
those things that are beyond the limits
of human imagination and so you know so
I thought it would be interesting to see
one of the animated shorts that he
produced during the World War two period
there's now this is some of the work
that comes out of the capper unit it's
from a series of shorts called the
private snafu series which were made for
American servicemen but this also
involves a representation of community
the homefront and its relationship to
the war so if we couldn't go ahead and
play that
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so that's the kind of stuff one of the
kinds of projects that soos was working
on in the in the World War two period
and gives you a taste of the adult
version of CSIS humor so up until World
War two soos would have been least as
well-known as someone who worked in
advertising and produced a distinctive
style of comic advertisements someone
who had been a propagandist an editorial
cartoonist and an adult humorist and
only would a secondarily have been known
as a children's book writer he had only
done a handful of children's book write
these stories at that that point in time
in his life indeed by the late 1950s
when the film featured will shouted on
5,000 fingers of dr. T came out the
reviews almost none of the mentioned
Seuss as a children's book writer
there's a recognition of who Seuss was
but all most of the reviews seemed
almost surprised that he was turning his
attention to children at that point in
his career but the techniques that he
would use in his later children's book
were already taking shape through all of
those other other practices so I wanted
to show a second cartoon this was from
the studio upa upa was created by labor
organizers who had gone on strike at
Disney crossed over and created their
independent animation production company
which sought to embrace modern art style
techniques many of them were influenced
very strongly by children's art and
particularly the way children's art
styles crossed over into modern art
styles so they were interested in people
like Paul Klee who was similarly
interested in how children drew the
world how children saw the world Seuss
had written a story called gerald
mcboing boing for radio and you can tell
that it came for radio because sound
plays such a central role in this
particular narrative but Gerald were
born boring is a story about a
remarkable boy and I think you'll see
why is the story continues but it's
about what does a society do with kids
who are different what is what a society
do in the 1950s with kids who don't fit
into the established norms and grooves
so let's go ahead and play that
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so I've always thought it was
interesting that gerald mcboing wearing
comes out at about the same time the
ferdinand the bill comes out a story
about a bull who doesn't want to fight
and comes out alongside Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer a story about the kid
knew the deer who's the other who's not
allowed on the other reindeer games that
there's a whole set of stories of that
post-war generation that are really
struggling through metaphor through
fable to talk about how does a society
deal with diversity and how does a
society deal with nonconformity and I
really you know it connects particularly
I think this is where it really starts
to connect because this is a central
concern of post-war child bearing guides
as well for the permissive books of dr.
Benjamin Spock which really shaped the
child-rearing practices of the post-war
generation really reflected a similar
view that the child's desires are
natural their curiosity should be
fostered their sense of experimentation
should be reinforced because out of that
curiosity comes an innate sense of
justice of civility of personal growth
and the way you do it is to redesign the
family so that it accommodates
children's desires and pleasures rather
than shuts them down the desire was it's
part of this democratization of the
family I've been talking about and so
the kid when people moved to sombreuil
Seuss they were reading Seuss in one
hand to their kids and reading dr. Spock
for themselves at the same time trying
to make sense of what this new family
should be like what the structure should
be like in their desire to rid the world
of future Hitler's as one of the writers
the period put it by getting rid of the
infantile behavior the sense of
repression and suppression that led to
dictatorial personalities and that's
really deeply embedded in the the ways
this generation thought about raising
its children so the film you'll see
tonight 5,000 fingers of dr. T comes out
of that same period indeed what you'll
see if you look at it is a lot of the
imagery around dr. terwilliker in his
Institute comes straight at
or to there's a direct ripoff from
triumph of the will at a certain moment
in there where German propaganda films
are sort of imitated to make fun of the
inflated authority figure of dr.
terwilliker z-- you know you and and it
was set up to be the its idea of the
piano school as a repressive environment
where kids are stripped of their toys
their comics their balls are taken away
from them as they enter into the space
and they're forced to conform to the
master desires of the citta latarian
personality and that's really the spirit
of this film but you will also see a
very clear articulation there's a
wonderful song in there about the power
of adults and kids and it sort of
challenges adults than not to push
little kids around there are songs about
the imagination that are woven through
there and there finally is this moment
where the young man stands up to
Authority overturns the school shatters
that the institutions that have been set
up to repress it and so we as Seuss
wrote it you could see him moving from
imagery of the war in the imagers
imagery of the home and its function
simultaneously as an retelling of the
narratives of World War two including
the plumber figure zabladowski is a kind
of arch typical American who doesn't at
first want to get involved to resist you
know participation but gradually learns
the importance and responsibility of
standing up against abuse of authority
so there's that all of the imagery is
there but so is the beginnings of a new
configuration of the family and the
relations between mother's sons and
fathers that comes to me and I think
that's what makes it a really powerful
story we see the same appeal to the
imagination and a lot of the post-war
books and I thought I'd picked I could
have picked any number of those stories
about kids you know running institutions
through Seuss Road if I could run the
zoo if I could run the circus but it
sort of about kids getting access to
power and how they would run things
differently or the stories like King
stilts which are about the value of play
or the the Bartholomew Cubbins stories
where again the young boys
up to Kings I you know there's on beyond
zebra about the kid who realizes the
alphabet is should not be seen as a
limit point that we should imagine
things that are alpha but don't allow us
to talk about it but I chose this time
scrambled eggs super which I hadn't read
in a long time and I thought it also
captures that sense of taking the
menagerie taking all of these strange
creatures that had been part of Souza's
early work and connecting them in
powerful ways to kids imaginations and
so I suspected a lot of you would not
have heard this one before
it comes out from 1953 I don't like to
brag and I don't like to boast said
Peter T Hooper but speaking of toast and
speaking of kitchens and ketchup and
cake and kettles and stoves and the
stuff people bake well I don't like to
brag but I'm telling you Liz that
speaking of cooks I'm the best that
there is my only last Tuesday when
mother was out I really cook something
we're talking about you see I was
sitting there resting my legs and I
happened to pick up a couple of eggs and
I sort of got thinking it's sort of a
shame that scrambled eggs always taste
always the same and because ever such
since goodness knows Winn they've always
been made from the eggs of a hen just a
plain common hen what a dumb thing to
use when all of the other fine eggs you
could choose and so I decided that just
for a change I'd scramble a new kind of
egg on the range some fine fancy eggs
that no other cook cooks like the eggs
of the ruffle necked salimah cooks a
salimah cooks say that should be good so
I went out and found some as quick as I
could
and while I was lugging them back to the
house I happened to notice a tizzle
topped grouse on a tree down the street
and I knew from her looks that her egg
and the egg of the salimah gooks oughta
mix my tea well off to taste simply
super when scrambled together by Peter
teeth Hooper so I took these eggs home
and I frizzled them up and I added some
sugar 2/3 of a cup and a small pinch of
pepper and also a pound of horseradish
sauce they were sitting around and also
some
then I tasted the stuff and it tasted
quite fine
but not quite fine enough to make the
best scramble that ever has been made a
cook has to cook the best eggs ever laid
and so I drove to the country quite
rather far out and I study the birds
that were flitting about I looked with
great care at a mop noodled Finch I
looked at a Beagle briefed bald-headed
Grinch and also I looked at a shade
roosting quail who was roasting roosting
right under alas alack stale and I
looked at a spritz and a famil an old
wing J but I couldn't just stop I kept
right on my way cuz they didn't have
eggs they weren't lying vain that day
then suddenly boy up that hill a short
space Birds they were laying all over
the place great Pappy gay families with
uncles and cousins all lying fine
strictly fresh eggs by the dozens why
have to scramble more Super than super
scrambled eggs super-dee-duper duper
special deluxe ala Peter T Hooper I
picked out the eggs in a most careful
way I only picked those that I knew were
great eh I only took eggs from the very
best fowls so I didn't take eggs from
the twiddle er owls because I knew that
the eggs of those fellow fellows your
twiddle tastes sort of like dust from
inside a vast fiddle I went for the kind
that were mellow and sweet and the
world's sweetest eggs or the eggs of the
Queen which is due to their very sweet
trout which they eat and those trout
well they're sweet because they only eat
wands and wands after all of the world's
sweetest frogs and the reason they're
sweet is whenever they lunch it's always
the world's sweetest bees that they
munch and the reason though bees can
taste sweeter than these they only eat
blossoms of bezel nut trees and these
bezel nut blossoms are sweeter than
sweet and that's why I nabbed several
eggs from the Queen but I passed up the
eggs of a bird called a strudel who's
sort of a stork but with fur like a
poodle
but they say for they say the eggs of
this kind of a stork or gooey like glue
and they stick to your fork and the
yolks of these eggs I'm told tastes like
fleece while the whites taste very like
very old bicycle grease the places I
hike to the roads that I rambled to find
the best eggs that had ever been
scrambled I hunted new birds along wild
tangled trails through gullies and
gulches down Dingles and dales I wiggled
my way and I crawled it a creep through
a forest of ferns that were 40 miles
deep and I mushed through the brush till
I found the fine quicker whose eggs are
as big as a pinhead no bigger then I
went for the eggs of a long-legged Quang
now this Quan well she's built just a
little bit wrong for eggs her legs are
so terribly terribly long that she has
to lay eggs 20 feet in the air and they
dropped with a plop to the ground from
up there so unless you can catch them
before the eggs crash you haven't got
eggs you've got long leg or hash eggs
I'd collected 302 but I needed some more
and I suddenly knew that the job was too
big for one fellow to do so i
telegraphed north to some friend's name
near fazool which is ten miles or so
just beyond the North Pole and they all
of them jumped in there Cata must slide
which is sort of a boat made of seal
upper tide which they sailed alt alpha C
to go looking for grits rice which is
sort of a bird which lays eggs on the
ice which they grabbed with the tool
which is known as a squid itch switch
because those eggs are too cold to be
touched without which and while they
were sending those eggs I got word of a
bird that does something that's almost
unheard of it's hard to believe but this
bird called the pelf lays eggs that are
three times as big as herself how the
pelf ever learns such a difficult trick
I never found out but I found that Ed
Greg quick and I managed to get it down
out of the nest and home to the kitchen
along with the rest but I didn't stop
then because I knew of some ducks by the
name of the
we'll file some Xion sucks who stroll
single powell file through the mountains
of zomes quite oddly enough with their
eggs on their thumbs and some fellows
and sums where I happen to know just
happen to capture a thousand or so and
they wrapped up their eggs and they
mailed them by air mark special delivery
handle with care I needed more helpers
and so for assistance I called up a
fellow named Ali long distance and Ali
as soon as he hung up the phone picked
up a small basket and started alone to
climb the steep crags and the Jags of
mounts truck ku to fetch me the egg of a
mist of a mount stroke ooh
cuckoo now these mounts Turku cuckoos
are rather small gals but these mounts
Turku cuckoos have lots of big pals they
dive from the skies with wild cackling
shrieks and they jabbed at his legs and
they jabbed at his cheeks with their
yammering clamoring hammering beaks but
Ali poor brave Ali he fought his way
through and he sent me that egg as I
knew that he would do for my scrambled
eggs super-dee-duper duper special
deluxe ala Peter T Hooper and the
meanwhile of course I was keeping real
busy collecting the eggs of the three i
lashed tizzy they're quite hard to reach
so I strode on the top of a homonym
akaash nom Iike schnapps
they'll I found a great flock of south
west facing cranes and I guess they got
something that's wrong with their brains
for this kind of crane when she's
guarding her nest will always stand
facing precisely Southwest so to get at
those eggs wasn't hard in the least I
came from behind from precisely
northeast and I captured the egg of a
Greek League raucous who lays up high in
a prickly cactus then I went for some
zips there exactly like zaps but the
zips live on cliffs and the zephs live
on Bluffs and seeing how Bluffs are
exactly like cliffs it's mighty hard
telling those ups from the Zips
but I know that the AG that I got from
the bluffs if it wasn't as if from the
cliffs was his offs now I need an egg of
a moth watching Steph who's an a bird
who's so big he scares people to death
and this awfully big bird well the
reason they named her the moth watching
Steph is because they that's how they
tame her she likes watching Moss sort of
quiets her mind and while she is
watching you sneak up behind and you
yank out her egg so I got one of course
with the help of some friends and a very
fast horse if you want to get eggs you
can't buy at a store you have to do
things never thought of before well to
get at the eggs of one's very small dude
off you had to pry all of one mountain
top off then I heard of some birds who
lay eggs if you please that tastes like
the air and the holes and Swiss cheese
and they live in Biggs Inns of ours ends
of our trees so I order a tree full the
job was immense but I needed those eggs
and said hang hang the expense I needed
one more and I saved it for last the egg
of the frightful bombastic aghast and
that bird is so mean and that bird is so
fast that I had to escape all agility
just a fleet-footed beast who can run
like a deer would look sort of different
you steer him by ear all through with
the searching all through with a looking
I had all I needed and now for the
cooking I rushed the kitchen the place
where I'd stacked them I roll up my
sleeves I unpacked the
and crack them and shuck them and chuck
them in 99 pans and I mix in some beans
I use 55 cans then I mixed in some
ginger 9 prunes and 3 figs and parsley
quite sparsely just 22 sprigs
when I added 6 cinnamon sticks on a
clove and my scramble was ready to go on
the stove you know and you know how they
tasted they tasted just like tasted
exactly exactly just like scrambled eggs
super-dee-duper duper special deluxe ala
Peter tea hooper only two or three of
you are of that age remember those books
very vividly and the rest of you
probably managed to escape Sally Dick
and Jane almost entirely so in an act of
cultural vengeance I thought it would be
useful to share Sally Dick and Jane or
this crown and if we're going to put on
video
a documentary restaged what took place
in classrooms when Sally Dick and Jane
books were being taught
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay let's I will take you out of here
mercy I will show mercy and take you out
of your misery I mean but I wanted to
sort of set that up because and since
that's what Cat in the Hat was written
in reaction to write that John Hirst
sure she the journalist had written in
Life magazine a piece about why Johnny
couldn't read and one of his answers was
that Johnny was bored silly right this
technique that had been used that was so
repetitive and so literal-minded you
know and there if we'd continued there
was a whole thing about how the picture
had to look exactly like the thing it
represented there could be no room for
confusion that you know realism was the
only acceptable aesthetic for children's
literature and that this was what
dominated schools and libraries in many
regards the otamatone aesthetic is a
very realistic and her she said what if
the best writers the best writers whimsy
and nonsense of the imagination wrote
books for children to read in schools
and he specifically called out dr. Seuss
and said dr. Seuss should not just be
writing for older kids but should be
writing for beginning readers to get
those kids to engage in literature in a
new way so Seuss took on the challenge
and try and you know he struggled quite
a bit because he when he were into the
trolls publishers for young children
there was a lot of resistance to the
idea that someone like Seuss could write
a book for a beginning reader but there
was also a kind of dick School Board
dictate that said there's a list of
about 200 words and you had to use those
words and only those words in telling
the story so all of those imaginary
phrases that Seuss created and those
books had to go out the window we
couldn't make up silly words with silly
sounds and strange consonants he had to
actually use an existing vocabulary of
words and at least as he tells the story
he was he played around with a list the
first two words he came up with it rhyme
that made sense to him was the Cat in
the Hat and the story that would emerge
really Wood Wood was going to be his
chance
I'll tell a story now they've just
published a really nice book the
annotated katma hat which takes page by
page and offers commentary on a story
I'm not going to go through all the
commentary here but I thought I would
share I would break it up a little bit
with some pieces of commentary as I read
but I think the the the thing to think
about is I wanted though some of those
phrases from there the reference to
Sally that can Jane the sort of domestic
setting that phrase up up up to come
back to sort of think about how those
all of those images come back in this
book that Seuss created the Sun did not
shine it was too wet to play so we sat
in the house all that cold cold wet day
i sat there with Sally we sat there we
chew and I said how I wish we had
something to do - what - go Alvin drew
called to play ball so we sat in the
house and we did nothing at all so all
we could do was to sit sit sit sit
and we did not like it not one little
bit and then something went bump how the
bump made us jump we looked and then we
saw him step in on the mat we looked and
we saw him the cat and the hat and he
said to us why do you sit there like
that I know it is wet and the Sun is not
sunny but we have come we can have lots
of good fun that is funny I know some
good knee games we could place at the
cat I know some new tricks said the cat
and a half a lot of good tricks I'll
show them to you
your mother will not mind at all if I do
then Sally and I did not know what to
say our mother was out of the house for
the day but our fish said no no make
that cat go away tell the cotton hat you
do not want to play he should not be
here he should not be about he should
not be here when your mother is out no
no have no fear have no fear said the
cat my tricks are not bad
the Cat in the Hat well we can have lots
of good fun if you wish with a game that
I call up up up with the fish
put me down said the fish there's no fun
at all
put me down said the fish I do not wish
to fall have no fear I said the cat I
will not let you fall I will hold you up
high as I stand on a ball with a book on
one hand and a cup on my hat but that is
not all I can do said the cat look at me
look at me now said the cat with a cup
and a cake on top of my hat
I can hold up two bucks I can hold up
the fish and a little toy ship and some
milk on a dish and look I can jump up
and down on the ball but that's not all
oh no that's not all look at me look at
me look at me now it is fun to have fun
and you have to know how I can hold up
the cup and the milk and the cake I can
hold up these books and the fish on a
rake I can hold up the toy ship in a
little toy man and look with my tail I
can hold a red fan I can fan with the
fan as I hop on the ball and that is it
all oh no that's not all that is what
the cat said and he fell on his head he
came down with a bump from up there on
the ball and Sally and I we saw all the
things fall and our fish came down too
he fell into a pond he said do I like
this oh no I do not this is not a good
game said our fish is heal it no I do
not like it not one little bit
now look what you did said the fish to
the cat now look at this house look at
this look at that you sank our Tory ship
sinking deep in the cake you shook up
our house and you bent our new rake you
should not be here when our mother is
not you get out of this house of the
fish in the pot but I like it here oh I
like it a lot sat the cat mat to the
fish in the pot I will not go away I do
not wish to go and so said the cat nap
so so so I will show you another good
game that I know and then he ran out and
then fast as a fox The Cat in the Hat
came back in with a box a big redwood
box he was shot with a hook now look at
this trick said the cat take a look then
he got up on top where the
for this hat I call this game fun in a
box said the cap in this box are two
things I will show to you now you will
like these few things so the cat with a
bow
I will pick up the hook you will see
something new - thanks and I call them
thing 1 and thing 2 these things will
not bite you
they want to have fun then out of the
box came thing two and thing one and
they ran up Ranger was fast they said
how do you do
would you like to shake hands were thing
one and thing two and Sally and I did
not know what to do so we had to shake
hands with thing one and thing two we
shook their two hands but our fish said
no no those things should not be in this
house make them go they should not be
here when your mother is not put them
out put them out set the fish in the pot
have no fear little fish said the Cat in
the Hat these things are good things and
he gave them a pat they're tame oh so
team they've come here to play they will
give you some fun on this wet wet wet
day now here's the game that they like
said the cat they like to fly kite said
The Cat in the Hat no not in the house
of the fish in the pot this is not
flight kites in a house they should not
all the things they will bump all the
things they will hit oh well I like it
not one little bit and then Sally and I
saw them run down the hall we saw those
two things bumped their kites on the
wall
bump bump from bump down the wall in the
hall think two and thing one they ran up
they ran down on the string of one kite
we saw mother's new gown her gown with
the dots that are pink white and red
then we saw one kite bump on the head of
her bed then those two things ring of
ran about with big bumps jumps and kicks
and with hops and big thumps and all
kinds of bad tricks and I said I do not
like the way that they play if mother
could see this Oh what would she say
then our fish said look look and I first
shook with fear your mother's on her way
home do you hear or what was she do to
us what will she say well she will not
like it to find us this way so do
something fast at the fish do you hear I
saw your saw her your mother your mother
is near so as fast as you can
think of something to do you'll have to
get rid of thing 1 and thing 2 so as
fast as I could I went after my net and
I said with my net I can get them I bet
I bet with my net I can get these things
yet then I let down my net it came down
with a plop and I had them at last these
two things had to stop and I said to the
cap now you do as I say you pack up
those things and you take them away oh
dear said the cat you did not like our
game oh dear what a shame what a shame
what a shame then he shut up the things
in the box with the hook and the cat
went away with a sad kind of look that
is good said the fish he has gone away
yes but your mother will come she'll
find this big mess this mess is so big
and so deep and so tall we cannot pick
it up there's no way at all and then who
came back in the house why the cat held
no fear of this mess of the cat my hat I
always pick up my playthings and so I'll
show you another good trick that I know
then we saw him pick up all the things
that were down he picked up the cake and
the rake and the gown and the milk and
the strings and the books and the dish
and the fan and the cup and the ship and
the fish and he put them away and then
he said that is that and then he was
gone
with the tip of his hat then our mother
came in and she said to us - did you
have any fun tell me what did you do and
Sally and I did not know what to say
should we tell her the things that went
on there that day should we tell her
about it now what should we do well what
would you do if your mother asked you
and I've always loved that last passage
which sort of gives permission for kids
that have fantasy lives to have secrets
to have a world of their own that not
necessarily exposed to adults and you
picture this read in school by a teacher
read at home by a parent or read by the
kid themselves it seems to permit which
is the classic notion of a permissive
environment to permit to allow to
tolerate to facilitate kids having an
imaginary life at kids being creative
and you read it alongside that Sally
Dick and Jane Passage and you sort of
realize what a act of liberation that
writing was you know how transgressive
it was in terms of taking that for cat
limited vocabulary and you know using it
like a sauna as a set of constraints to
create with him as a way to invent and
articulate something different for the
imaginary lives of kids and that's what
I think the dr. Seuss books meant for my
generation which was the first to grow
read them growing up as they were coming
out every year at Christmas a new dr.
Seuss book and that was really the heart
of why I've drawn toward the sort of
celebration of dr. Seuss and his work I
think there are many values there that
are worth holding on to as we move into
the future as we create a future at MIT
and we create a future that's on beyond
that goes on beyond zebra so the close
today I thought I would read one last
book and it's one that Seuss wrote
specifically about politics he said this
book Marvin K Mooney will you please go
now was written in the midst of the
Watergate scandal and he was very
explicit and some correspondents at the
time that he really was thinking about
Richard Nixon when he wrote this book so
I thought a week after Obama takes
office for some strange reason this book
popped into my mind and I thought it
would be a good place to end as well as
being a book about farewells and
goodbyes so change glasses again
the time has come the time has come the
time is now just go go go
I don't care how you can go by foot you
can go by cow Marvin came Unni will you
please go now
you can go on skates you can go on skis
you can go in a hat but please go please
I don't care you can go by bike you can
go by as Ike bike if you like if you
like you can go in an old blue shoe just
go go go please doo doo doo Marvin came
Unni I don't care how Marvin came Unni
will you just please go now
you can go on stilts you can go by fish
you can go on a croak car if you wish
you can wish you may if you wish you may
go by lion's tail or stamp yourself and
go by mail Marvin came Unni don't you
know the time has come to go go go get
on your way
please Marvin Kaye you might like going
as humble zing you can go by balloon or
broomstick or you can go by camel in a
bureau drawer you can go by bumble boat
or jet I don't care how you go just get
get yourself a kazoom you can go with a
broom Marvin Marvin Marvin will you
leave this room Marvin came Unni I don't
care how Marvin came Unni will you
please go now
I said go go and go I meant the time had
come some Marvin went
so thanks for listening in just a minute
we'll start 5,000 fingers of dr. t which
is an astonishing film and one that's
well we're seen it's rarely shown so I
hope you'll stick around it's written
and designed by dr. Seuss in the 1950s
it's sort of like what would happen if
Leave It to Beaver had an acid trip I
think
and it's definitely we're seen as it
happens the boy who's in the film turned
out to be the original owner of lassie
before Timmy on the television series so
he is indeed an icon of the 1950's
generation so enjoy thank you thank you
very much